et on revient à l'actualité avec ce
rappel des titres à présent dans le set
suite le rappel des titres de ce 28
janvier la manifestation en faveur du
mariage pour tous a réuni entre 125
mille quatre cent mille personnes dans
les rues parisiennes nous en parlait au
début de cette édition elle parmi eux
des syndicats étudiants des lycéens
également de 50 ans nülink y ont pris
part ils sont partis avec de versailles
dimanche matin tout savoir de la police
technique et scientifique 50% des faits
élucidés dans le département le sont
grâce aux technologies de recherches
physico-chimiques une équipe de soixante
huit policiers est dédié à cette
expertise le commissaire en charge de la
police technique et scientifique était
sur ce plateau
vous retrouvez son interview sur notre
site internet dès demain matin
en sport le challenge des crimes de
trappes traditionnel challenge
interclubs 160 tireurs présents dans les
yvelines également à des hauts-de-seine
et de seine maritime au classement final
le vésinet le club de brice guyart
double champion olympique au fleuret
l'emporté devant tram et comment
apprendre à se défendre en cas
d'agression un stage de self défense
associé à du kickboxing était organisée
à bois d'arcy et là aussi si vous
souhaitez revoir ce reportage rendez
vous pour le replay sur notre site
internet ou lors d'une prochaine
diffusion du 7 8 et l'actuel toute image
de la rédaction ce sera à 20h30 un mot à
présent sur les nrj music award ça n'a
rien à voir avec le sport et pour autant
on va revenir sur ce prix obtenu à
cannes par shy'm l'artiste né à trappes
a fait ses débuts dans les yvelines à
saint quentin en yvelines où elle a
grandi avant de s'associer aux
producteurs camaro en 2005 elle a reçu
samedi soir le prix là de l'artiste
voilà pour les images le prix de
l'artiste féminine francophone de
l'année
une dernière récompense avant de faire
un break dans sa carrière c'est elle qui
l'a annoncé une artiste qui a fait
beaucoup parler d'elle notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux et pas uniquement pour
le prix qu'elle a obtenu aussi en raison
d'une séquence que vous allez apercevoir
dès à présent et c'est cette séquence
qui a fait beaucoup parler si on peut
voir les
voilà pour la conclusion anthony vous
êtes resté en plateau juste pour revoir
ces images j'en suis sûr ce baiser
lesbien avec l'une de ses danseuses à la
fin de son interprétation directe un
engagement sans doute en faveur du
mariage pour les personnes du même sexe
n'est pas la première fois
madonna avait fait la même chose il ya
dix ans aux états unis sont toujours en
avance effectivement voilà ce qui nous
amène à parler de l'information du
week-end c'est cette mobilisation en
faveur du mariage pour tous avec cette
mobilisation départ depuis 50 ans en
yvelines dimanche matin le débat sur le
mariage pour tous s'ouvre à l'assemblée
nationale ce mardi
dimanche entre 125 milles et 408
personnes étaient dans les rues
parisiennes pour clamer leur soutien ce
projet de loi et dans le cortège des
étudiants du syndicat unef et du
syndicat lycéen une aile parmi eux les y
du mois
partis en fin de matinée de la gare de
versailles chantiers comme sébastien
étudiant au lycée hôtelier de saint
quentin en yvelines
ce n'est pas sa première manifestation
et ce combat s'inscrit dans les valeurs
de son syndicat s'est toujours battu
contre les discriminations que ce soit
les discriminations face au racisme les
discriminations
face au au sexisme et aussi les
discrimations face à l'homophobie
et aujourd'hui on est dans la rue parce
que toute avancée sociale qui permet de
dison banaliser l'homosexualité à la
société c'est un progrès pour nous c'est
pour ça qu'on est là pour défendre ça
c'est important de montrer que le projet
du gouvernement compte qu'il est soutenu
par une grande majorité de la population
les étudiants divinement rejoint le gros
de la troupe sous une bannière commune
unef une aile
il était environ 10000 à défiler parmi
les autres manifestants une mobilisation
qui a convaincu sébastien il s'est dit
satisfait tout en déplorant le manque de
couverture médiatique
quant aux opposants au mariage pour tous
il ne baisse pas les bras
samedi le collectif yvelinois la manif
pour tous appellent à se rassembler à 15
heures devant la préfecture de
versailles pour demander le retrait du
projet de mariage d'adoption et de
procréation médicalement assistée fin du
set 8 je vous retrouve en direct demain
mardi 18 heures avec de nouveaux invités
notamment un point complet sur la
situation à flins est également au
technocentre à guyancourt nous parlons
de renault avec une situation qui se
complique jour après jour les salariés
et qui sont mécontents et qu'ils le font
savoir 7500 postes sont amenés à
disparaître en france dans les deux
prochaines années les syndicalistes
mobilisés seront sur ce plateau une
mobilisation est d'ailleurs annoncée
demain matin du côté de flins excellente
soirée à demain